Welcome to Unit 5. Today we talk about actual robot motion.
In the previous unit we talked about how to find paths .
Now we'll talk about how to turn these paths into actual motion commands.
In particular, we'll talk about generating smooth paths.
Then we'll talk about control.
In particular, a method called PID control.
As usual, you get a chance to program all these wonderful things.
You might be remember that our planning took place in a discrete world,
and the type of plans we found look very much like this,
perhaps in response to obstacles over here.
Now, a path like this has lots of disadvantages.
You don't want to a robot to go straight, take a 90-degree turn and go straight again.
For one, a car can't even do this, but for another this will force the robot to move
really slowly around the corner over here.
A much better path would look like this.
This is a smoother path.
In the extreme case, you might even generate a path just like this.
The question becomes can we modify the blue path to look more like the red or the green path?
Suppose your car like a robot right over here wished to get to right over here.
Which path would you prefer?
The blue path, the red one, or the green one?
Just check one of the three.
This is a question where I check your intuition. This is not a mathematically precise question.